joining me on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line right now on the rich eisen
show is the quarterback of the los
angeles rams getting set for a monday
night game in arizona huge contest no
question about it it's matthew stafford
how are you matthew
i am doing good rich how you doing i'm
doing better for talking to you i'm not
lying on that front um the the burning
question of the moment matthew i'm sure
you've been asked quite a bit is die
hard a christmas movie let's get right
into it very important to hear from you
what do you consider i have uh i have no
feelings on that at the moment to be
honest with you i'm a little uh a little
swamped with what's going on in my world
but uh we'll say no
you know what i knew you and i
were seeing eye to eye ever since i met
you ever since i met you
do you remember the first time we met
matthew because i do you remember this
oh
uh i can't recall all right here it was
here it was it was the night before your
draft it was me you and mark sanchez in
new york city for a little q a for for
for you know an aside and you were you
were not yet a detroit lion and your
life was about to change and i remember
you walked
to the event and i asked how much money
was in your wallet you do you remember
how much money was in your wallet at the
time i don't know what did i have a
single dollar like it was like it was
trading places like seriously
and it was amazing like your life was
about to completely change and it was
but it was cool it was really cool way
back in the day man you know yeah that
was back in the day wasn't it it was see
i'm trying to just get you out i see you
did you just like come out of a film
room or something like that is it are
you like that like that locked in right
now right now i've been watching a
little bit of tape wouldn't watch a
little bit of tape with these guys so
i'm trying to get ahead a little bit all
right very good um i feel like i'm i'm
taking you away from that but i i just i
just want to ask you a few questions
how are you feeling that's so much of a
conversation about your health right now
matthew yeah i feel fine uh i don't
really know
why or where that came from to be honest
with you we're all dealing with stuff at
the nfl it's week whatever it is now and
everybody's dealing with something but
uh nothing that's protecting my play i
feel healthy every time i go out there
to play i feel like i can play at a high
level so um and put that one to rest
okay put it to rest and this is not like
the quarterback i'm not going to use it
as an excuse answer like literally
you're feeling fine and you can you're
you're you're good
right now yeah i'm good i'm good okay
very good on that front um and then uh
the addition of odell beckham where
where is he do you think in
uh knowledge of the playbook comfort
level you and him being on same page
things of that nature right now yeah i
mean i think um what he's been able to
do in a short period of time as far as
understanding what we're trying to do
and accomplish offensively is pretty uh
pretty impressive to me i didn't know
what the you know what kind of exposure
you have to an offense like this and
truthfully didn't have much um you know
verbiage-wise or anything like that that
was much carryover but he's done a great
job kind of just jumping in and
the good thing about right now in a
season rather than you know training
camper you're trying to get every single
play you're ever going to run in the
entire season
in in a three week period right now our
game plans are pretty succinct you know
they're pretty tight and he can kind of
go in there learn his role figure out
what we're trying to do that week go out
there and execute it and last week was a
good uh you know a good example of that
had a nice catch on a on a bootleg and
then had great touchdown catch we just
missed on another one down the field so
his role is growing uh but i have been
really impressed with what he's been
able to do in such a short amount of
time because you know everybody just
assumes you know he's odell beckham and
this is an offense in the nfl and we
should start seeing fantasy football
type numbers like his first year you
know i mean that's the general
the general sense how people view things
yeah i mean what do you i mean it's it's
such a big you know undertaking to to
move teams to move your whole life
um you know in the middle of a season
like that and try to come in and produce
at a high level i still think when you
see it on tape you watch him move it's
still all right there i just you know i
got to continue to work with him
continue to uh you know give him
opportunities and he's done a great job
of capitalizing on those opportunities
uh when i give him something and of
course he arrives just as a time where
it's you don't talk about adjustment i
mean uh
you know i think it's stipulated how
terrific robert woods is at his job
and at his position how has that
affected um everything with you for you
this offense so far yeah i mean you know
robert does an unbelievable job you know
running routes and catching the ball um
you know what goes kind of unnoticed is
some of the things he's able to do in
the run game and uh just the mentality
that he brings he is an ultimate
competitor he's a guy that uh you know
goes to a different place mentally on
game day and we miss that guy because he
was such a
he was such a dog he was such a
competitor he loved going out there and
competing and he made everybody else
around him better so we definitely miss
him we're doing everything he can to
have everybody else step up and play at
a higher level to help you know pick up
the slack um but there you know there's
an adjustment there and i feel like uh
you know we're going to have to continue
to do that throughout the season matthew
stafford rams quarterback here on the
rich eisen show before monday night
football so um
the uh uh you used to be on twitter so
uh this v this video went viral maybe
it's you still aware of it cooper cup
after the victory against jacksonville
asked about his touchdown reception
gave a very clear and concise but very
detailed answer x's and o's did you see
that video did that cross your path uh
yeah
uh i'm i'm not on any social media but
uh i was i was texted that from actually
andrew whitworth
um you know
with the with a little bit of a chuckle
there but uh that's coop you know that's
coop he uh he understands the game at a
at a really high level and uh
wanted to show off a little bit of the
uh
mental prowess i guess yeah my gosh i
mean that was uh that was a beautiful
mind at work no question about that
why have you and he been able to be on
so uh so same page since john yeah
matthew you know i think
um you know i think uh he obviously
understands the game you guys got a
little you know glimpse into that um you
know with that interview but uh i just
think he's a really you know really
talented player you know um does a great
job you know whether he's inside or
outside
running routes catching the football
he's really good after the catch he
understands what we're trying to do with
each play and how we're trying to scheme
it up
and um
you know sometimes guys are easy to
throw to sometimes guys are difficult to
throw through he's one of those guys
that
you know since the first time i played
catch with him um you know he's one of
those guys that's just easy to throw to
and um you know he's done a nice job
obviously this season leading the league
in a bunch of categories and playing at
a high level and
the cool thing for me is you know i get
to watch him run all these routes catch
these paths to score touchdowns do all
that kind of stuff and then you put the
tape on and he's uh you know comboing
with our right tackle on a
on an outside zone play leading up to a
nickel like a tight end i mean he does
it all and he's a you know big part of
our team's success
so um
the question about this team over the
last month prior to jacksonville is what
happened with the offense because it
wasn't nearly as dynamic uh as the first
third of the season first half of the
season and then of course defensively uh
teams kind of jamming the ball down the
rams throat in a way that we hadn't
really seen that either
uh was the jaguars the get right game do
you think here or
what what happened i know i'm asking you
two questions in one but just the
general sense of uh of the rams not
looking like the rams over the past
month would be what
matthew yeah i think um you know every
game is its own proving thing you know
proving ground uh you know so you got to
take them all individually and i
understand that um and you look at those
games that you know we did lose uh we
turned the ball over you know you turned
the ball over on offense and a lot of
those were in either you know return for
a touchdown or backed up you know where
the other team is set up for success
right away so we put our defense in a
tough spot and when i say we majority of
those were me you know so uh i could do
a better job and then you watch the game
on sunday and you play jacksonville and
you don't turn the ball over and uh you
know those things don't happen so gotta
make sure we we take care of the
football and obviously i touched the
ball
uh you know on every single play and so
it's my responsibility to make sure we
do a better job of that and looking
forward to
you know doing that the rest of the
season and the uh the challenge this
week is what since you said each game is
its own proving ground this is as a huge
a game as possible uh
uh i don't need to tell you what the
math is two games back right now uh and
having the uh
uh an opportunity to even the series
rather than being swept by the team
that's two games in front of you this is
as crucially important a game as any
against the cardinals what do you got
for me yeah definitely
yeah absolutely um you know
going to their place you know a
difficult place to play team that plays
uh you know high quality football seems
like every sunday they do a great job
i've got a dynamic quarterback with a
bunch of playmakers and they're running
the football really well as well
and then on the defensive side of the
ball um a really fast and physical
outfit you know i think you look
both uh you know from the safeties all
the way down to the you know interior
d-linemen
um they run and hit they've got a great
scheme they're well coached and they
play uh you know really hard so it'll be
a big matchup for us it'll be a lot of
fun um you know a big challenge for us
going on the road to their place trying
to get a
big road win in the division what's it
like watching film with mcveigh
so far first three months
it's great um you know the way he sees
the game is really uh you know it's
pretty special i think he um understands
not only you know how to attack teams
but how to put our own players in uh in
you know positions to succeed um you
know that's such a huge part of the
chess game in this league is not only
being able to dial up a play that should
work against a certain coverage or a
certain front or whatever but being able
to do it uh you know personnel driven as
well is pretty awesome have you been on
the business end of his famous memory
like telling you about one snap that
happened in a five second span 13 weeks
ago and stuff like that have you seen
that that's daily
really that's daily yeah you know it'll
be uh yeah we did this and this in this
year at this place
and then sure enough he goes and pulls
the clip up and it's it's right there so
it's it's impressive um you know
smarter guys i've been around
all right last two for you they're
they're uh holiday related questions
matthew stafford first thing what was it
like not playing on thanksgiving for the
first time maybe since college
for you yeah it was strange you know to
be honest with you i loved playing on
thanksgiving um you know you didn't have
to uh we played the early game in
detroit always at home so i was at my
house at about 5 5 30 able to just stuff
my face with turkey inside and i had to
kind of dial it back this year because i
had a friday practice coming in
from the game so i had to uh i had to
watch myself dial it back
i missed it you know
that's interesting because you could
just screw it i'm on a mini buy i'll
just go for it right on the thursday
uh-huh absolutely but now you had to
dial it back all right and then last one
is uh what are you doing new year's eve
matthew what are you up to on new year's
eve what are you doing i know what
you're doing not much not much you're
sure
yeah am i do we have a game on new
year's eve i don't look that far ahead
of them there is a game on new year's
eve uh it's your alma mater versus mine
yeah
um we have a casual
oh
matthew stafford
you don't really want to put a parking
spot on the line do you here in los
angeles california do you well i mean
considering i still don't know where
this parking spot is
[Laughter]
all right um no no no how about this how
about this what about i do do i wear
something georgia on
nfl network and then you've got to wear
something michigan for your press
availability what do you think yeah i
can do that yeah we can do that okay
okay so this is real whoa this is real
yeah man
okay
so uh cause there is uh so let's do this
so that's december 31st and so
there is a football sunday on the second
i will go on nfl network um what do i
have to wear for a segment what do you
think what am i gonna do i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna be cruel and unusual here
okay i can just wear it for a second red
tie for a segment no no no no no i'm not
gonna that's a whole show no this is
this is no no chris you back off be
quiet
so
so a segment i'll wear a segment you you
could send me a georgia uh what hat or
something like that or whatever i'll get
something for you okay i'll wear a hat
and then you'll get a michigan hat and
so for your press availability would you
meet the media on a wednesday is it when
you meet him yeah usually on wednesday
okay on a wednesday the following
wednesday of that week you'd have to
wear something uh you have to wear a
michigan hat for that thing perfect done
wow you're feeling good in red
[Laughter]
all right matthew stafford this is what
we uh what the kids would say lit this
is gonna be great okay
thanks for the call matthew i love it
you take care of yourself you be well
all right man thank you there you go
that's matthew stafford of the los
angeles rams right here on the rich
eisenhower hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here